you just excusé aujourd'hui se
retrouvent surface personnes l'obr dans
le jeu dans lequel tu fais la guerre
mais avec la mouvance pas très clair
pour moi n'est ce pas on est un homme
s'il vous plaît oui connexion chez eux
il ya un avion il ya un pistolet bisous
l'objectif c'est de libérer le monde de
la haine apparemment population infectée
château un sponsor un cachalot à
éradiquer le monde de l'aef donc on doit
retrouver de la bourse a salué le délire
je suis prêt l'argoat que l'amour soit
avec toi elle a dit c'est drôle un ogre
et le met carrément sa part sur du sport
c'est sa part sur de hip hop et ça ça
part sur une certaine homosexualité en v
ou en mission patron oui a lancé alors
à taylor le maïs au dessus des avions
comme ça calmement quoi ah oui bien sûr
puis s'envole comme superbe à ok tat
j'en vois quoi je ne sais pas dekker
partout pour atterrir dedans olala c'est
stylé 1
nous appeler pour un novice
donc choisir faut que tu aies descendre
la boue il a l'air d'avoir plein de
haine tu as peu aux mondiaux ouais je
lui envoie des bisous
aux plages les libérer hors du coup il
ya plus de haine en lui c'est ça il s'en
va il est très heureux papa pas gta se
joue en hiver les légendes comment
comment tuer deiter à assas et un
générateur de haine quelque chose comme
ça il faut qu'on le détruise ouais bah
du coup regarder tout est mignon et aux
alentours lui il est encore plus heureux
libéré le reste de la zone mais c'est
parti on y va mon gars alors attendez
excusez moi vous êtes un petit peu et ne
faisait dès 8 heures ce pardon et tu vas
faire bitches je vous libère quand même
sujet grille est très mignon bien sûr au
nom pas tout à jeter c'est bienvenu et
je te pousse même je t'amène dans la
petite ruelle sombre là bas avec l'autre
homme vient avec moi jackson jackson
2nde à la femme ses deux filles allaient
bien que moi j'ai fait une blague du
ltte plein mois sur l'autre cette galère
à il faut que je monte pour avoir une
meilleure vision de la ville tradition
qu'est ce qui se passe elle a dit
qu'elle n'a jamais vu autant de haine il
me faudrait un plus puissante elle m'a
dit d'attendre pour un air drop qui
tombe décapage sous forme de coeur je
suis l'homme de la situation c'est comme
ça qu'on
attend le juste rêve sa part au stade
soit plein pour envoyer des coeurs
d'aller tous décédés plus tard oui le
générateur il faut qu'on trouve un
générateur c est compliqué sa jugeote je
l'entends mondiaux et aussi lomba être
[ __ ] de pigeons mon but c'est de tout
mettre nu mais ensuite de pas à deux pas
vous retirer votre haine je veux bien me
soigner mais si vous n'êtes ni
uniquement bien sûr au lumignons
regardons y aura un petit poulet un
petit poulet qui va finir dans un stand
de hot dogs allez hop ça dégage jeunes
poulets à carreaux flux poc au mondial
quand tu sers moi vous envoie de l'amour
trop d'amour pour vous parce que je vous
aime a même tiré dessus et qu'on vous
êtes tous nus à tuer bien blanches tuant
de faire bronzer là-bas générateur ta ta
ta ta ta chevaux la moitié quoi dommage
car on espère pouvoir c'est sûr et
certain à mon dieu aie pitié à il veut
très l'hôpital générateur question
affaires bitches moi j'ai un shotgun
monga home surtout les filles souple et
les filles en premier à la serbie en
commandite les femmes et les enfants
priorité ben alors qu'est ce qui vous
arrive on use et abuse des eaux au total
édition cul de poule et attend on peut
pas vous rassembler pour faire un tas de
gens nus ça peut être drôle ça ça peut
se revendre cher sur ebay et voilà on a
constitué une véritable orgie sur la
plage et n'importe quoi à les enfants
sert de vous rendre vos habits
ça vous va ou quoi ouais et aux plates
faut savoir si tu veux être nue ou pas
tu peux pas faire l'entre-deux comme ce
que tu fais là vraiment c'est ce qu'on a
comme aux
mondiaux il arrive les renforts sont là
[ __ ] il est carrément pas se frotter
koudou maman non ok il faut pas de
menaces envers par tant de haine toi
t'as l'édition spéciale du cdh tu vas
être que jusqu'à la fin de ta [ __ ] de
vie au monde et reçoit centre commercial
de haters or il faut que je monte va y
avoir une grenade ours voilà je penserai
restant bien l'amour désolé je dois
interrompre et votre petite conversation
avec un peu d'amour mais du coup elle
est nue elle et tu peux y aller mais
c'est allé nulle petits poèmes dans le
seul jeu au monde dans lequel peut
mettre des gens nus comme ça quoi mais
oui je n'ai pas oublié inquiète pas
inquiète pas fait pas le foetus à vallée
d'ossau kuduro et danse vraiment le
kuduro sans déconner le combat laissez
nous battre comme ça quoi cinéma s'ouvre
au barça marché mouillart alors qu'il
suit sa biatch pis comme je dis souvent
un brett pas mes vidéos comme ça regarde
pas mes vidéos alors alors si tu auras
pas mes vidéos édition spéciale ta
gueule reigl biatch non toi tu es une
toiture mais tout à l'air chiante
telescope ou hst est dans la vie à l'ema
tendent est en toi non on passe temps on
y est hop là ok c'était grenade d'amour
qu'est ce que vous allez faire qu'est ce
que vous allez faire à il faut que
l'enceinte est dit est dit teddy bear
moineau faut qu'on
aille parce que j'ai dit trop de
formateurs fokker il n'a pas aimé sa
basse avec c'est une phrase de haineux
donc du coup le jeu a détecté çà comme
comme nocif il faut faire ça ça va tous
les attirer
j ai pas prévu le rechargement 300
boîtes à port salut ça va oui eh ben ça
va tâche moins jeunes qui se jouent en
bo1 jusqu'aux portes du rock c'est bon
il n'y a plus aucune trace de haine dans
cette ville désormais quand il ya une
porte ah oui comme ça je vais libérer
tout le monde etes-vous prêts aux maires
non mais chaque rester gentil alors ça
aime pas les bisous c'est pas les poux
touba vous voilà l'homme sprimont gars
qu'est ce qui se passe parce que l'amour
n'a pas de prix lorsqu'il faisait
compris allez salut c'est le nounours
across de
mahamane franco
[Musique]
excusez moi ça me prend des fois c'est à
force de combat de cesser ses noeuds là
ça me oui tu feras attention tu es tout
seul est plus maintenant à temps mais
ils passent de blanc à anwar il chante
couleur de peau comme ça il a l'air
d'être mis en moi en tout cas j'ai fait
moins la gueule alors s'en va ça dégage
il faut appeler l'ascenseur s'est dit à
la rescousse des dyslexiques a hâte et
disloqué été dispensés ou et un
certificat d'études en a pas à l'acheter
convoqué dans des cols ça arrive une
minute what you're gonna do you wanna go
1000 for you will meet pa il pouvait
m'aider comme j'ai sorti de lorraine
bordel de merde maîtres football et
commentaires sur youtube maintenant tu
es du jour que telle était pas mal celle
là de l'ascenseur est enfin là mais que
nous attend ici là ou plutôt je sens la
connerie ou alors grande vague de gens
pour changer ça c'est encore plein de
gens mégalo vous avez vu répandus un peu
l'amour sur cette chaîne youtube sans
bégayer c'est encore plus jolie mais là
ça faisait pas tout politique et on y va
en nageant h pas aux noms seront déçus
qu'il n'y a pas d'amour sans eau il n'y
a pas de hausse en amour et s'accrocher
parce que je dis oh oh mon dieu c'était
le dernier générateur de haine qu'est ce
que c'est que ça les vertes ont ça
tremble mon dieu
c'est le plus gros acheteur de tous les
temps c'est sa merde c'est quoi mais mon
dieu qu'est qui suivent affaires
attendent en fait non fait ne risque pas
t'as vu fais pas ça [ __ ]
on vous dira d'accord de lâches qui
volent huawei est alors
h une seule fois j'ai réussi au [ __ ]
c'est quoi ça tenait qu attendu déjà
pourquoi il est sur un super cheval
c'est un ours a souhaité une créature
haters aussi voilà cette hausse pose de
me commenter à ce que tu veux je le sais
oh mon dieu quel regard assez le plus
gros acheteur de tous les temps quoi
elle est peut pas m'atteindre sibat
nomades or le mec il beaucoup trop fort
quoi peut-être que le teddy peut retirer
ça alors tu étais tu fais un autre pour
femmes à ces bruits vulnérables
maintenant papa baba dans l'album chaude
qu'est ce qu'on fait on peut plus poster
un commentaire en bas âge ou alors en
place sur le crâne chauve en il paraît
que ça glisse mur je suis un [ __ ]
nietzsche a alors lâché le coach manu
chao j'ai plus de mal à aller y en a il
en reste un os non il a remis son
bouclier mamouri plus fort que toi pour
fêter ça je sortais une chanson jai mgmt
yeux j'aime ton crâne chauve tous tes
gestes et douceur oh non il est décédé à
nous je suis taillé chrono il nous a
battus vous et qu'ils en plastique tu
m'a peut-être arrêter mais tu n'as pas
arrêter cette roquette c'est ce qu'il a
dit as un missile et ne au salon s'est
contaminé il est amoureux maintenant il
va le manger d'amour il il va vouloir
s'accoupler avec lui à a arrêté sur faut
que j'arrête cette fusée avec tout
pouvoir de l'amour que je dispose je
peux le faire je
et voilà j'en suis enfin cette vidéo
j'espère si vous a plu et que vous êtes
littéralement purgé de votre haine
actuellement mais ça va regarder
n'hésitez pas vu les deux ça vous a plu
se montrera votre amour on est tous
amoureux aujourd'hui ça trop loin il
fallait se retrouve dans une nouvelle
vidéo tient tout le monde te caresse
dont tu me caresse pas
à temps mais ce genre de question qu'on
peut se poser quand quelqu'un allait me
dois quitter
ma [ __ ] je peux redevenir un bon gros
eaters alors je vais aller sur une de
mes propres vidéos tg fdp